when English actor Henry Cavill was
announced as the man who would lead
Netflix's The Witcher starring on the
Lauren Schmidt history created series as
the rugged monster hunter Geralt of
Rivia the Internet had a collective
breakdown fans of The Witcher both the
collection of books written by Andrzej
Sapkowski and the CD Projekt RED back
video game series based upon those
creative works where equal parts stoked
and skeptical about cavil portraying
such a beloved character you look like
trouble dead wrong
I make trouble go away I'm a Witcher how
well would he embody the silver-haired
beasts lair was he the right fit to play
the part we proved himself a worthy
witcher despite the show's grim and
intriguing trailers some people may have
needed a bit more time to be convinced
that cavil was absolutely the right
choice for Geralt but one person who
knew right from the get-go that cavil
was the one was Lawrence Schmitt history
herself looper recently spoke with
historic who opened up about how cavil
landed the role of Geralt in the witcher
according to history one reason why
cavil was a clear choice to portray
Geralt of Rivia who undergoes physical
training and intense mutations to become
a Witcher at Kerr Morin was because he
was already well versed in Witcher lore
book series and video game franchise
alike history admitted Henry is a huge
fan of the game we met very early in the
process and he had played all of the
video games he's quite the gamer himself
and when he heard that Netflix was
making a show based on the books he went
out and read all of the books though the
Netflix series hadn't started the
casting process when historic and cavil
met one another historic loved his
passion and enthusiasm for The Witcher
when his retired directors and writers
and began penning scripts for the series
that's when casting officially began mr.
ik explained that our approach to
casting as always quote to see everyone
to see different levels of actors from
all over the world people who are very
well known and people who've never been
on television before she and The Witcher
team wanted to ensure that they were
quotes exploring every avenue to find
the best Geralt and in the end his Rick
met with 207 potential Garrels
so how did historic land on cavil after
seeing hundreds of actors gunning for
the role of Geralt as she tells it she
simply couldn't get cavils voice out of
her mind while other actors auditioned
to lead the Witcher thus history knew
cavil was the perfect man for the job
I am what they said history shared at
the end of the day though I realized
that I actually kind of had Henry cavils
voice in my head and I called him and
explained basically this whole thing and
he was like great if you want me I want
you to know that I'm the right person I
want you to have seen everyone and met
everyone and we met up again and we
talked for several hours and by the time
we left that day I knew that I had found
our Geralt
as mentioned cavil had something of an
advantage going into the Witcher through
his extensive knowledge of the source
material as most already known Netflix
as The Witcher is based on Andre
sapkowski's books rather than on the
video game series story so cavil knew he
had to brush up on the narrative behind
the narrative of the games he played
through now at the thought of having to
read a ton of text before the December
20th premiere of The Witcher in order to
enjoy and understand the series has
suddenly sent a shiver down your spine
take a deep breath hiss rick has assured
that the show will satisfy existing
Witcher fans without pushing away people
who are unfamiliar with the property no
matter if you played The Witcher games
or have never picked one up before read
everything Sapkowski is written or
haven't gotten around to doing so it
seems you'll be pleased with Netflix as
The Witcher do not tell me that this is
finally the moment you've decided to
actually care about someone other than
yourself a touch brush she dished the
show has to appeal to and surprise
existing fans that's our core
enthusiastic bait part of what I've
loved and working on the show is getting
on at first twitter and then instagram &
even finally I got on reddit recently
and really sort of delving into the
fandom and seeing what they like what I
tried to do is take the stories that
they loved and they were familiar with
but to tell them in a different way
which is part of the structural changes
that you'll actually see in the show
we're sort of saying let's basically
present this story in slightly different
dressing she continued noting that the
series creative team kept in mind not to
quotes alienate people who've never
heard of The Witcher before and made
careful decisions to ensure that those
new to the property can enjoy the
upcoming series just as much as longtime
fans mister explained you want to make
sure that there's things for them to
fall in love with - for instance in the
first episode we only meet Geralt and
Siri I found that in trying to explain
what a Witcher was and to learn all of
these new names and all of these new
places and things that sound unfamiliar
and tried to wrap your head around the
politics of the world what I want to do
is hold off in
producing yennefer because i wanted to
make sure i was giving it in bite-sized
pieces and then what that allowed us to
do in Episode two was to let both Syrian
Geralt take a slight backseat and really
delve into yennefer and to make sure we
understand where she's coming from in
historic swards The Witcher is quote
really a mix of bolt tried to make sure
that the story is engaging for fans but
also really exciting for people who've
never heard of the project no doubt that
henry cavill x' handsome mug will also
pull viewers into the show the first
eight episodes of which hit Netflix on
December 20th check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite stuff
or coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]